hi I'm Greg hey my name is tarick taro
eek Tarek is a friend of mine from
acting class and Tariq is on snapchat
Instagram and Twitter so Rica two one
two
yes follow him there poor foot boards on
the orders they're gonna be like right
yeah it's like a text he ran out say
what how to spell it and stuff for
people to know hey tar here's him -
alien movie I've seen the alien movie
yeah there's this new movie with Jake
Gyllenhaal and Ryan Reynolds and other
people I saw the trailer a while ago
people are talking about this like it's
opposed to actually be really good
called life light and I hear it's kind
of a like somewhat in the vein of the
first thing and move interesting yeah
and this is the red band trailer several
people have sent this over
let's go watch this [ __ ] and do it
oh good thank you
[Music]
time to wash all the time just a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
whoa that was intense and creepy and all
sorts of things man dude if the movies
anything like that I'm gonna love it do
you like bored I like really it's
definitely up my yeah yeah it's like
thriller yet hard gets me just like wake
at night all the time I can do this from
what the other shredders show me it
looks more like a tension builder yeah
I'm not like in the vein of alien we
attention builder time sci-fi for you
there was a moment to hear they're
really like oh and then none nothing
will be like super [ __ ] man and like
there's an interesting effect for a film
you're not really seeing like bang I
mean it's right under the glove but like
watching it shrinking everything I was
disturbing watch but this crew dude poor
crew yo space movies make me never want
to go to space I'm the writing to movie
where they go to space and it turns out
okay like nothing always that
like it's like scooby-doo in space yeah
they make a fabulous place they should
now they should definitely cuz you
credit you for story i yeah i mean i
love the way there's another thing on
the other shows a small we're not edited
this way worth kind of frantic yeah it's
like a paranoia by daily and i mean we
were big words yeah and I really like
that frantic pace about it be honestly
cutting back boarding terror and before
the terror is apparent before that
errand suit and then like did the sound
effects is gold sounded oh they were
just on it man you're oddity making so
much more yet they look very eerie of
super suspenseful I wonder if we're
going to see like a full developed
version of whatever this creature is
because the first alien I mean I just
keep comparing it but I know that some
was like definitely in the vein of it
the first aliens you barely see the
healing you're the bed they don't know
you get like yeah yeah usually the
shadows easy in there for somebody being
dragged away yeah yeah so here you don't
really see a crisp clear image of the
creature so I'm wondering if we're
actually going to see that I like that
you barely see it it makes it even
scarier because you're not exactly sure
whatever the hell is morphing into
seriously well we know Rho anything is
definitely growing it's like a starfish
it looks like some type of yet win by
gala yeah yeah Patrick stars okay I like
this table must use was bottoms on
[ __ ] space and killing all these
people
yeah but they have a shower in Times
Square and everyone's gathered and I
guess I make sense where you see like
you know people probably hearing about
some freaky [ __ ] going on with mainship
right outside of Earth so I can get with
the fear suspense to get like they need
to get rid of this thing and kill it yet
before we go back to earth so I can get
to fall and kills anything yeah come
factory murders everyone undersea yeah I
mean based on what that tiny thing can
do to that hand imagine what a big
Google is lips full for no that's might
be I hope we get to see them I like that
I like how it's not showing us what this
monster is but it's getting me excited
for like another kind of sci-fi monster
in here it's like they took the Pokemon
manatee [ __ ] okay keep 30 cartoon now
Jesus having like to redo Patrick's okay
talking to managers there's a lot of
cartoon it just this is a live-action
cartoon what is it like a cartoon is a
lot of calculation right there's a shot
of Times Square and I kind of wish we
didn't get that Shawn time squared I
like it I would love it if you're at
this is only in space for beginning to
end true no yeah I don't want to know
about what's going on earth do i bill
add to the suspense if we know that like
it's Houston in them communicating back
and forth there's a shower right where
Jake Gyllenhaal closes door right around
so they'll like looking at each other
we've had that moment before knack
o'clock as we let me in the class yeah
can't let you in if I could in that
moment Jake Gyllenhaal will die because
I think he's like I think he's like
credited third or fourth on this movie
is okay so can get you on all the really
big actor so we're going to be credit
third or fourth kind of hints that that
idea that you might die I noticed that
with movies where if they're didn't if
it has moving eyes like if they're a big
actor and they're not wanted to talk to
you bill they're usually gonna die but
it was a small contained film whether
that's true yes elevation it would make
it wouldn't make sense like why are we
seeing Jake Gyllenhaal yellow it's black
dude the first one to die again with
this [ __ ] oh come on that's why I
brought you on this video it is
specifically why about I remember this
and I was like I wanna Contras haha
feeling day an hour well at least he's
like a NASA scientist you know yeah I'm
like randomly yeah I he putting like Wow
black people got down there [ __ ] that
guy is is a plane like a thug or
anything yeah he's like that's not good
they don't it's good they don't send a
dog in this video that would be a cool
area like I'm here with this [ __ ]
my bust is there can you manifest his
[ __ ] run they'll be hilarious hey there
yes you movie ideas and wondering yeah
yeah alright guys well thanks for saying
that was out you can subscribe the real
rejects hey Tariq carry tariqa it 21 to
it 2-1 to in area code no it's not yeah
Sarika see what's you for him over nap
shot and an Instagram
Twitter it fall him there he could use
the follow plan tell them yeah $34 our
Terrace is so real oh yeah keep
forgetting to say this that notification
bell click it is every youtuber says it
so now you got to click that
notification bell so you can be notified
you got to subscribe and then you got to
click another I know it's a lot of work
you use ask why why I know why two
things is if you have a subscriber you
she just she does automatically do them
you should automatically get Wi-Fi
physics to buttons then I'm you know I'm
looking to Belgium [ __ ]